avant-hier le juge hier le gendarme
aujourd'hui le journaliste les
journalistes mes confrères qui ont
couvert le drame de la vologne en
témoigner au procès villemin témoignages
nécessaires dans la mesure où les médias
ont contribué à l'agitation dans la
mesure où nous avons nous aussi notre
part de responsabilité dominique
verdeilhan eric de lannion dès le 17
octobre 1984 sur les bords de la vologne
il y avait plus de journalistes que
d'enquêteurs isabelle bechler pour
antenne 2 et laurence lacour pour europe
1 était sur place
cette dernière depuis a quitté la presse
par dégoût reconnaît-elle on a dit
beaucoup de choses qui ont dû salir
l'honneur de ces gens là on a vécu dans
le règne de la rumeur c'est vrai nous
nous sommes pris au jeu de la recherche
et laurence lacour de regrettait ce vent
de folie ce défoulement collectif mais
de dénoncer aussi les conférences de
presse quotidiennes des gendarmes un
geyser d'information dit elle et de
dénoncer enfin le fait qu avocats et
juges choisissent est leur interlocuteur
dans la presse si on n'a pas
d'informations pour les autres on est à
la traîne et comme on ne pouvait pas
vérifier parce qu'elles soient les
autorités judiciaires et proprement
à l'abandon soit les autorités
policières gonfler tout uniquement pour
alimentation cela a débuté de france
vous pouvez nous faire dire n'importe
quoi
l'arrestation de bernard laroche à son
usine on nous l'a apporté sur un plateau
reconnaît isabelle bechler une ambiance
de lynchage peu propice à la présomption
d'innocence et les deux journalistes de
confesser l'hypothèse christine villemin
était certes la plus folle mais aussi la
plus médiatique est la plus vendeuse
excès de mots excès d'image confesse
aujourd'hui les journalistes qui
regrette cette instruction parallèle
d'être devenus des magistrats par
procuration incompatibilité entre la
logique du fait divers est la logique de
justice
mais tous les journalistes qui se
succèdent à la barre depuis plusieurs
jours rappelle que la presse toutes
tendances confondues a prévenu gendarmes
policiers juge d'instruction des menaces
qui ont pesé à l'encontre de bernard
laroche
hélas ces mots-là la justice ne les a
pas entendus